hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
factor five expression and xp chose cell
presented by dr laurel monye
associate professor molecular medicine
scripps research institute
i'm christi jewell of labert and i will
be your moderator for today's event
this presentation is brought to you by
lab roots and sponsored
by thermo fisher scientific for more
information on our sponsor please visit
thermofisher.com this presentation you
are about to see was previously recorded
but i would like to remind you that this
event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type
them into the ask a question box and
click send
dr monye will answer the questions via
the contact information you provided
at the time of registration if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
use that ask a question box and let us
know you're experiencing a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
your presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i would now like to introduce today's
speaker dr laurel monier
associate professor molecular medicine
and scripps research institute
dr monye holds a phd in thrombosis and
hemostasis from utrecht university in
the netherlands
he has worked in a variety of roles over
nearly 20 years
at scripps research institute in la
jolla california
most recently as a tenured associate
professor his recent work includes
developing a targeted therapy for acute
traumatic bleeding dr monye will now
begin his presentation
thank you very much um thank you for the
invitation to uh to share with you
tonight um solve
some of our experiences um with the xp
uh chose cell system um
before i begin i like to thank uh
bill g joseph who will be done most of
the work that uh
i i'll be presenting and also um i'd
like to mention that these studies were
done in
collaboration with hematerix and as well
with thermal fissure and i'd like to
thank them very much for all their
contributions that they made and
help that they gave us just as a way
of a background my lab
at scripps is a basic academic lab
i'm interested in blood coagulation
proteins and my specialty is a strong
structure function of blood coagulation
proteins
we generally try to engineer proteins so
that they have beneficial
activities either in situations of
bleeding of
in situations of thrombosis or in
situations where where cognition and
inflammation coincide such as sepsis or
other inflammatory diseases a couple of
years ago we became really interested
in um bleeding diseases
and and because we figured that there's
really not that much out there
in way of uh treating bleeding diseases
and
an understanding of the mechanisms of
bleeding um
in particular we became interested in uh
acute traumatic bleeding
um as a way of of mechanism but also
because there are no
it's a major clinical problem but are
currently very little
suitable treatment options the available
pro-hemostatics that are out on the
market
they're very good at stopping bleeding
but they also come with a risk of
thrombosis and especially in
multifactorial traumatic bleeding
they carry an unacceptable high risk of
thrombosis with them
so when we're working on trying to
figure out okay what mechanisms are
involved in traumatic bleeding
we realized that we had a engineered
coagulation factor 5 molecule that had
properties that were very beneficial or
deemed
to be very beneficial in in the
situation of acute traumatic bleeding
and so we proposed that this engineered
factor v molecule
could actually be a target therapy for
acute traumatic bleeding
so we went on in the lab in mouse models
to show
efficacy of this model and we showed
that it
reduced bleeding and acute trauma it
prevented acute traumatic cogalopathy to
develop which is a consequence of acute
shock
um it works in hemophilic bleeding and
in it stops bleeding associated with
direct oral anticoagulants and a bunch
of other bleeding
um indications so at that point we
we for ourselves we were convinced that
you know the molecule actually works or
has a chance of working at least in
these mouse models
um but we we were hit with another
problem
and and that is well how are you going
to produce it so if you're thinking
about translational or preclinical
development
how are you going to make this molecule
and so the goal of this presentation and
and the goal of this whole
uh project was to evaluate the
feasibility of
a pre-clinical slash commercial skill
production platform
um for recombinant factor five and the
reason why that was a little um
uncertain or at least carried some risk
with it is that there's currently no
um precedent for commercial production
um
of recombinant factor five at least not
in the public domain
and it's a big molecule it's uh over 2
000 amino acids it's heavily
glycosylated
has a molecular weight of a little over
300 000
um dalton uh there are multiple
disulfide bridges and the plasma
concentration is in the order of 10
micrograms per milliliter
now there there is a homologous protein
factor 8 which is also a coagulation
factor that is
being commercially produced by numerous
companies as a treatment for
hemophilia a um and so so there are some
similarities
um in in that that is possible but you
have to realize that the plasma
concentration of factor eight
um is at least ten fold lower so
if you think that well you you need to
achieve about
equal dosing as plasma levels then you
know we
we needed to be able to show that our
production could um
be ten times as good as what is out
there for factor eight
now in order to simplify um
the the expression of this recombinant
protein um
a part of the b domain uh which is
indicated here at the bottom
is deleted and that that makes a big
difference because it's it
truncates the the protein by about 700
amino acids
it takes about away about 25
glycosylation sites
and after activation by the coagulation
cascade or in the test tube
after uh after purification before
administration
um this whole b domain is cleaved out
anyway so you still end up with the same
normal activated factor five
so this is where we were when we started
this project
our lab scale production of factor five
we were using a so-called ped vector
which is a bicestronic vector with a
dhfr
it's developed in 19 well published in
1991
by randy kaufman who works at the
burnham institute
um the production was done in adherent
bhk
cells which came from dr kamir and and
typically
we had an expression level of one to two
milligrams per liter
um not great but enough to do
to purify a few milligrams for air for
mouse studies
um so really when we started this
project the basic questions were well
can we reach to um an expression goal of
about 50 milligrams per liter given that
we're in academic lab that not
everything is perfect
if we reach the 50 milligrams per liter
then more professional
commercial entities will have room to
optimize that further to
what will be considered a viable um
production yield
but but but that presented us with
questions well
how we're going to start uh which vector
are we going to use
and which cells are we going to use um
we had doubled a little bit
around before uh with pc uh dna 3.1 and
adherent 293 cells which are i mean
in which we basically express all our
other correlation proteins
and that was a complete and utter
failure we didn't see any expression
so to be honest i was a little hesitant
when we started this
now luckily um and and thanks to
chairman fisher
we were able to make some initial
handway and and so the plan was to to
try transient
trans transfection in the expeditio and
in the xb293
system to kind of see which cell line
would be most
suitable and then as for vectors
and i must admit this was something that
i wasn't aware of
until was pointed out to me is that the
pc
dna 3.1 vector that we use in all our
academic expression and
systems actually has a truncated cmv
promoter
so the first thing that that was
suggested is well you got to try to
treat the
sorry pc dna 3.3 or 3.4
that have a full length cmv promoter and
then in addition
the pc dna 3.4 also has what they call a
woodchuck
transcriptional regulatory element
that that further stabilizes messenger
rna so
okay well we'll give it a try so we got
the pc dna 3.4
um put in the construct and and gave it
a try and much to our
excitement and enjoyment um
the first try in the exp cho which is as
shown on on the on the left here
um really improved expression compared
to what we're used to seeing in our bhk
cell line that is shown all the way on
the left
so here's an example of of the culture
soup harvested at either at day 8 or at
day 10
using the pc dna 3.4 vector and compared
to our
ped vector that we were used to using
which
basically did not improve expression of
um
above the bhk cells
so th this was really intriguing and so
we were wondering well
what is it in this vector that's really
so good and and the other problem is
because the protein is so big we're
hitting uh we were a little over 10 kb
and we were worried that the plasmid
became too big so
we decided okay let's take this
woodchuck element out there and see if
does that really make a difference
so on the right side you see um the
comparison of pc dna 3.3 versus 3.4
this is done on an adherent show k1
cells um but as you can see
the the the woodchuck element really
seems to make a difference even if it's
only in the order of about two times
um there is a consistent uh improved
expression when that element is is
present so that was great so
now we had confidence that this pcb in a
3.4
is capable of at least greatly improving
expression
um which brought us to our next question
what cells should we use so this is
again the left side the same xp show as
cells
this is derived from 30 ml cultures i
believe
and on the on the right side is the same
vectors and done at the same time in the
xb293 cells
and there is nothing there or very
little there so this explains why our
dabbling with the pc dna 3.1 in the hand
heck was
such an other failure why this
difference occurs i have no idea okay
i can tell you um but but it is
consistent
and and so apparently there's something
in the xp chose cells
that that for this particular protein
works a lot better
so that's great so now we have a cell
line that is um
that is feasible to to use that
expresses
uh a number of times better
um so how can we improve this
so the next step is that um well
if you read the manual there are these
two methods or or three methods maybe
for transfection and for culturing this
so-called standard protocol
where feed is given on day one and the
culture temperature is
37 degrees and in the so-called marks
max tighter protocol where there's an
additional feed at day five and and the
temperature after transfection is
lowered to 32 degrees
so as well does that really make a
difference and as you can see here yes
it makes
a difference if you use the the culture
temperature at 32 degrees
you get again a little less than a
two-fold improved
expression so good so so although we
couldn't be sure that it's the
temperature or
versus versus the feet um certainly
something to keep in mind
the other thing that was really
interesting is that and i don't know if
you have noticed the pattern
is that these were harvested around day
seven day eight
but as you go on with later harvest date
the the activity of the protein
decreased
so we're wondering well maybe we're too
late in harvesting maybe there's
something going on that's decreasing the
protein
let's do a time course and let's see
what's happening
well when we did the time course and
this is shown here in the xp
show transient transfection in this case
we use the pc dna 3.4
with the max protocol and the culturing
at 32 degrees
you see that there's a very rapid
increase in in expression um
up to about day five and in black you
see the activity
and in the open symbols it's the antigen
and generally activity and antigen
coincide quite well up to
to about day five what's amazing is if
you look at the expression level so now
we're hitting 80
milligrams per liter in this relatively
unoptimized
system and so we already reached our
initial goal that we thought was really
high
of 50 milligrams per liter
now if you look at what's going on so
obviously after they
starting at day four but after day five
something is going on that is degrading
the protein and you can see that on the
on the western blot
um on the right side in the in the in
the bar on top that's our protein of
interest that's what we want
and so you see the accumulation of
degradation
products but you can always harvest a
little earlier before the degradation
takes place we can figure this out later
these data were so exciting to us that
we
we decided okay let's go ahead let's see
if we can make a stable cell line out of
this
and so we use the the the expeditiosl
um to give it a try and and make stables
the the pc dna 3.4 has a neomycin
selection cassette
in there um so what we did is we did the
transfection
um 24 hours put the selection media on
there
let the pool select for about two weeks
and then after two weeks we did dilution
cloning to to get our monoclonal cell
line
we tried it a few times but
unfortunately um we were not successful
in getting any good expressing clones
why is that well we thought maybe um
our you know you pick up the fastest
in in this pool you pick up the fastest
growing cells
maybe if if the cells need to express
this protein
it gives them a growth disadvantage so
maybe we're just outgrowing
the pool so we changed our approach a
little bit so we did the transfection
and and then decided to do the dilution
cloning and the selection at the same
time
um it's a inefficient pro process we did
about 10 plates
a lot of empty wells were the results
but that way
at least if you have a slow glowing
clone
that is a high producer you you'll
capture it right from the beginning
as you can see from the templates we had
i don't know what is that about
20 20 clones that were um
interesting and one that with the red
circle
um was actually the the highest
expressing clone and so i'll talk more
about that particular clone
i just wanted to make the um remark that
there's a solution for this and um
that's uh doing the
the the selection in semi-solid media
and it worked really well and then
that's shown on the on the right
the problem is that we didn't have an
automated clone picker
um so so we were limited to
to letting the clones grow to a certain
size so that we could pick them up
by eye the other problem is that with
automated clone picker
you can use a fluorescent antibody that
kind of binds to your protein of
interest and forms a halo
around the clone so you can select for
high expression clones versus slow
expressing clones
and i think if you have that technique
developed or if you have an antibody
that works with that
then this is a really good solution for
this overgrowing of the pools
nevertheless for us i worked at just um
doing the dilution cloning
and the selection at the same time so we
picked we went on with this clone c4
we did all the steps that you're
supposed to do made sure as monoclonal
did a second sub-cloning
we tested that it was expressing for at
least uh 30 passages
um made sure there was no contamination
did the banking etc
but the bottom line is that when we
looked at it
in a 30ml culture oh yeah and i should
mention that um because we are
cash trapped academic lab um we decided
to go with the freestyle show media
instead of the
little bit less budget friendly
expression media
that is typically used in the transient
transfections
nevertheless we we we saw a similar
pattern
as that we saw with the trenchants
before and
they express really well up to about day
three day four
and after that the expression levels uh
drop they average
expression levels now and um we're about
30 milligrams per liter
which is a little lower than the highest
that we saw in the transient but still
very good
and so we were trying uh different ways
with batch feeding
and see if it could you know stretch out
its expression time
and get the levels up and so that's
shown on the right um we decided to
to replace the medium every uh three
days fifty percent of the media replaced
and then uh do that um
in subsequent days and at least for a
couple of days we
were successful to increase production
we even went up to 150 milligrams per
liter
um but but then i guess the the waste
products in the culture took over and i
must admit we're not measuring
ammonia glucose oxygen levels were just
not set out for that
but this gave
a really good feeling that we can
achieve high expression
in stably transfected xp cho cells
however the eureka moment for us came um
when we were going over the data again
and say hey how can we improve this now
further
and then um we realized that why don't
we give it a try at 32 degrees
i mean that's that's the max protocol
that showed that huge increase
in the in the transient um why wouldn't
that work in this table as well
so what you what you see here is the uh
the the time course of the expression
either at 37 degrees of the stable clone
in green or at 32 degrees in the
um of the stable clone in red
and as you can see there's a huge
difference for this particular clonin
since we only selected the few clones
and and continued
only one i don't know if this is
specific for this particular clone or if
we can
uh generally extrapolate this to other
proteins or other clones as well
um but but for us this was a a huge
breakthrough
we set out to try to express 50
milligrams per liter now we can
routinely achieve 100 150 milligrams per
liter
without too much problems
the other thing that's really
interesting if you remember in the
transients we had this problem with the
degradation
and all these degradation products that
were formed
and as you can see here unless you get
to the really end of the curve
the amount of the degradation products
is is a lot less
and so this is really clean
so in conclusion um for us this uh
transient transfection in the xp
show and the xb293 systems
provided a robust screening method for
the initial selection
of which expression vector to use and
which cell line
to use and the occurring expression
levels after transient transfection
they they prompted us to to spend the
effort and time to generate as a stable
cell line
and the expression levels of factor five
in this stable transfected xp
show sl exceeded expectation
and provide a high level of confidence
that the commercial skill
production of factor 5 in expeditio s
cells
is feasible and certainly with further
additional optimalization
it should be no problem i think on that
part it's important to note that a fully
documented
uh gmp banked xp show s cell is now uh
available
and also that a recently released xp
chose stable production media
is available that is more in the same
price class as the fishtail show
compared to the expression media which
for us that's important
um i didn't i didn't show you the data
because it's still too preliminary in my
view
but we we have tried some expression
with our stable clone in the stable
expression media
and it certainly provides a big increase
compared to the freestyle medium and
it's very sim
similar in expression levels uh compared
to the
expression media that's used in the
transition so
with that i'd like to thank therma
fischer for their help
along the way and i'll happy to answer
any questions
a big thank you goes out to dr monye for
his excellent presentation
now if you do have any questions you
would like to ask dr monye
please type them into the ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen
dr monye will be answering questions via
the email address you provided at the
time of registration
i would like to thank labyrits and our
sponsor thermo fisher scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labberts will alert you via emails when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's event
you will now be redirected to the
registration page of our next summer
future webinar
xp 293 new tools for structural biology
and difficult to express proteins
presented by dr john zamuda director of
cell biology
life sciences solutions group thermo
fisher scientific
this event will broadcast on december
10th at 8 a.m pacific time
that's all for now and we hope to see
you there